let's say you disagree with the
political views of the people who run
the country the billionaire class the
Tesla drivers are self-appointed clergy
on social media the retired prosecutors
and spy chiefs you so often see on
television opining about things if
you're watching this show you're
probably not all that impressed by these
people you don't wish them personal harm
of course some of them are well-meaning
people but you don't think they've done
a very good job for America though
somehow they themselves are richer than
ever you might have voted for Donald
Trump to make that very point have you
ever considered what these people think
of you for voting the way that you did
for daring to be insolent and
disobedient how would they punish you if
they ever got the chance ever think of
that
well wonder no more yesterday Paul
Manafort received four years in prison
for bank fraud and tax evasion
Manafort will be seventy years old in a
couple of weeks he's got no criminal
record of any kind his sentence is
considerably longer than the national
average for the charges that he pled to
but a time Manafort gets out of prison
he will be elderly broke and disgraced
but for a ruling class that's not nearly
enough punishment Manafort briefly
managed Donald Trump's presidential
campaign and for that they believe he
must die in prison
anything less cannot be allowed shocking
news shocking and I'll tell you as a
former prosecutor I'm embarrassed
as an American I am I'm upset from the
very beginning this judge seemed to have
had a hard-on for just the mullet robe
overall it's a serious crime and he got
a slap on the wrist and I think for that
people should be outraged
I find this jaw-dropping really that's a
Brian it's an extraordinarily lenient
sentence in light of the extent and
scope of mr. Madoff for criminality Paul
Manafort got the special club'
Washington elite friendly treatment it's
an outrage and it's disrespectful of the
American people Paul Manafort must die
that's what they're demanding Robert
Muller agrees with them Muller asked
that Manafort receive up to 24 years in
prison
for perspective that is more than twice
what the average murderer in this
country spends behind bars that's a
death sentence keep in mind that serial
murderer Al Capone only got
11 years for crime similar to those that
Manafort has been charged with but
Capone was just a gangster Paul Manafort
is an enemy of the Democratic Party and
that's much worse is there a single
person in America who believes if mana
furred would be going to jail if he
hadn't run Donald Trump's presidential
campaign everyone in Washington knows
that there are a lot of Republican
consultants here who are grateful
tonight that they didn't take the job
they're heading out on spring break
tomorrow Manafort is heading to prison
the judge in the case clearly
understands what's happening here as he
passed down his sentence judge TS Ellis
reminded those watching that mana furred
was quote not before this court for
having anything to do with collusion
with the Russian government to influence
this election that's literally true
Manafort has not been charged with any
crime related to Russian collusion
nobody has been charged with a crime
related to Russia inclusion that's a
fact it's not an opinion there's no
dispute about it and yet somehow a lot
of people are still out there lying
about this probably because no one in
the press ever calls them on it watch
your elected officials say something
totally untrue in the most
self-righteous possible way the American
people would be justified in feeling
that there has been some miscarriage of
justice here
what Paul Manafort did was essentially
potentially threaten our very democracy
the principles of our democracy this
news came out about Paul Manafort and
I'm really ticked off about this were
you shocked that he only got 40 so this
criminal justice and can't surprise me
anymore it's a sentence that is far too
short you know I think I spent more days
in detention in high school than judge
Ellis thinks that Paul Mann afford I
should spend in jail so cory booker is
quote very ticked off that Paul Manafort
may not die in jail for cheating on his
taxes keep in mind this is the same cory
booker who recently has spent hours on
the Senate floor wagging his finger in
the face of America over mass
incarceration our broken justice system
the same cory booker who worked so hard
to reduce the sentences for fentanyl
dealers and applauded when the bill
passed yet that's also the same cory
booker who now is outraged that a tax
cheat isn't getting the death penalty as
cory booker ever cheated on his taxes
hope not
that'd be hypocrisy need to be
interesting to know it would be
interesting to know if any of these
hyenas circling Paul Manafort has ever
fudged a did
chin or somehow violated our complex
banking laws somebody should check the
penalty is pretty high these days just
kidding
this isn't about taxes obviously Cory
Booker knows that well it's about using
power to crush your political opponents
in order to get more power the same
principle be on display next week when
Manafort is sentenced for failing to
register under the foreign agent
Registration Act of 1938 that will be an
amazing moment if only because of how
rarely it occurs it's like Halley's
Comet here in Washington in the space of
50 years between 1966 and 2015 the DOJ
charged a total of seven people in
ferret cases just three of them were
convicted meanwhile the most powerful
foreign lobbies in Washington still are
not registered under Farah Robert Muller
has no plans to indict them of course
not they never made the mistake of
running Donald Trump's presidential
campaign